Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est dimanche et donc c'est le jour des explications.
Une fois par semaine, j'invente un tour et je vous l'apprends
pour que vous puissiez bluffer à votre tour vos amis, votre famille, votre entourage.
Cette vidéo se passe donc en deux temps. Dans un premier temps, je vous fais le tour, à vous là directement, à travers l'écran.
Et dans un second temps, je vous explique comment ça marche.
Regardez bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout. A la fin des explications, je vais vous donner deux trois détails qui sont importants.
Pour ce tour, je fais péter la playlist !
Je vais vous faire voir une partie de ma playlist, à moi, personnelle, dix titres à moi et vous allez en choisir un dans votre tête, dans votre esprit.
Un et un seul que vous allez fredonnez dans votre tête ou à voix haute d'ailleurs.
Vous pouvez vous faire un kiffe !
Moi je vous ai promis que je ne chanterai plus donc je ne chanterai pas quoi qu'il arrive. Il n'y a pas de problème !
Dix choix possibles. (Énonciation des titres sur l'écran)
Abba avec ...Ah! je sais jamais comment le prononcez ça... Je parle pas suédois les amis !
(Suite de l'énonciation des titres)
Dix titres. Parmi ces dix titres, vous en sélectionnez un dans votre esprit
et vous commencez à le fredonner, à le chanter, même si vous connaissez pas très bien les paroles
au moins l'air un petit peu qui vous revient.
Je vous laisse quelques secondes. Quand je claque des doigts, faut que votre choix soit fait quoi qu'il arrive.
(Claquement de doigts) C'est bon !
Continuez de fredonnez un petit peu l'air dans votre tête, essayez de voir le chanteur devant vous...
Oh j'ai l'impression que c'est un chanteur dont on avait parlé dans la chaîne...
Pour une des astuces du mercredi...
Attend !
Je vais, j'vais chercher dedans.
Franchement vous fredonnez très très bien dans votre esprit.
Et je pense que cette intro va vous parler.
Je coupe ! Sinon je vais avoir des problèmes de droits d'auteur sur la chaîne.
Parce que oui ! Je le sais, vous aviez choisi Stromaé.
Et pourquoi j'en suis si sûr ?
Bah parce que c'est moi qui ait créé ça ce matin.
Donc forcément...
Est-ce que ? Est-ce que je vous le dis d'ailleurs ? Est-ce que je vous l'explique ?
Evidemment !
C'est parti pour la partie : explication...
Dans la liste il y avait dix choix possibles avec dix groupes très connus ou dix chanteurs très connus
Il y a des plus actuels, il y a des plus anciens. Des français, des américains. Même des suédois.
Il y avait de tout. Et pourtant, vous êtes allés sur Stromaé quand je vous ai un petit peu speedé parce que (x4)
Parce que c'était le seul que vous connaissiez !
Vous connaissiez tout les artistes, oui !
Mais vous ne connaissiez pas les chansons.
Parce qu'elles n'existent pas !
Je les ai juste inventées ce matin juste avant de faire la vidéo !
Reprenons dans l'ordre, parce que la cinquième, elle va vous faire marrer.
Il y avait Nirvana avec Today is all, Sinsemilia avec Pourquoi pas ?
J'ai essayé à chaque fois de trouver des noms cohérents.
Stromaé, Tous les mêmes, donc ça c'est bon.
Metallica Two for two. ABBA avec Latnem Golv.
Alors, golv ça veut vraiment dire étage en suédois, mais c'est surtout que latnem golv, si vous l'écrivez à l'envers, ça fait mental vlog.
Oui ! Ça m'amuse, et alors ?
Je cherchais un truc qui faisait suédois, en fait.
Johnny, Donne-moi ma chance. Bon il en a fait tellement que ça passait...
Euh Eminem Take me more, Fréro delavega, Je l'entends venir. Je les vois bien sortir un titre qui s'appelle comme ça.
M C'est pour elle. C'est sûr, un jour il sortira une chanson comme ça aussi.
Et Michael Jackson, c'était le risque avec Not Afraid parce que les vrais fans de Michael Jackson savent que ça n'existe pas.
Vous pouvez faire ce tour à quelqu'un, pour ça dans la description, je vais vous mettre un petit lien qui va vous permettre de télécharger la playlist.
Et pour le réaliser vous présentez la playlist à une personne, vous lui laissez dans les mains,
vous lui demandez de choisir un titre qu'elle est capable de chanter dans sa tête, de fredonner même si elle ne connait pas très bien les paroles.
Au moins que l'air lui revienne.
Vous lui laissez quelques secondes, vous récupérez la liste.
Pas la peine de lui laisser éternellement parce qu'elle peut voir la supercherie si elle est fan de l'un des groupes, genre de Nirvana ou de Michael Jackson.
Ou de Johnny, si c'est votre père. Et comme révélation, je vous propose soit de faire comme vous me voyiez faire dans les vidéos avec un bloc-notes et puis un crayon.
Ou alors, ça peut être assez marrant,
vous pouvez mettre la main sur la tête de la personne et de faire semblant de percevoir des choses et commencer comme ça lentement à faire -chantonne-
Ha ha ! J'avais dis que je ne chanterai plus.
Et beh... Je le re-dis, je ne chanterai plus.
Vous pouvez donc commencer à fredonner la chanson comme si vous perceviez un petit peu de sa tête à votre bras à votre esprit.
Et je pense que la personne sera d'autant plus bluffée que vous le fassiez comme ça.
Précision ultimement importante ! Comprenez bien que si par le plus grand des hasards ça n'a pas marché sur vous par la vidéo
les tours que je vous explique c'est pour les refaire à d'autre personnes, donc en live, en réel.
C'est bien normal que parfois, par vidéo, ça ne marche pas.
Vous pouvez mettre pause, vous pouvez chercher sur internet en même temps...
Vous avez pas forcément la même concentration je ne peux pas gérer les personnes indépendamment une à une.
Ne vous attardez pas à ça si jamais, par malheur, ça n'a pas marché. Si ça a marché vous pouvez me le dire dans les commentaires, je les lis tous !
Surtout testez-le, vous pouvez même le faire dès aujourd'hui parce que là il n'y a pas besoin de trop trop répéter en plus.
Je pense que vous allez vous éclater avec ça.
Et si vous aussi vous le pensez, si la vidéo vous a plu, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un... où est-ce que je l'ai mis d'ailleurs ?
Pouce en l'air !
Et j'ai changé de côté.
Merci à vous tous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si jamais vous êtes un nouveau sur la chaîne, n'hésitez pas, vous pouvez penser à vous abonner, ça ça fait bien plaisir.
Et sinon rendez-vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain mental vlog,
Ciao !